Peace and blessings be upon the Messenger of Allah, his family,
his companions, and those who follow his guidance. Now,
we have reached the statement of Al-Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, in the
chapter on the Prophet's saying, peace and blessings be upon him, "This
wealth is green and sweet." Allah, the Exalted, said, "Beautified for
people is the love of that which they desire -
of women and sons, heaped-up sums of
gold and silver, fine branded horses, cattle and
tilled land.
That is the enjoyment of worldly life." Umar said, "O Allah, we cannot help
but rejoice in what You have made beautiful for us. O Allah, I
ask You to let us spend it in Your cause." In
the name of Allah, and all praise is due to Allah, and peace and blessings be upon the
Messenger of Allah, his family, and all his companions. Now,
Sheikh Khalid Al-Dhafeeri, may Allah preserve him, said, may
Allah have mercy on him, peace and blessings be upon him,
this hadith that was mentioned in the chapter on wealth being green and sweet, we have already discussed it. He
mentioned the verse in which Allah, the Exalted,
informs us about what has been made beautiful in this
worldly life, of various kinds of worldly pleasures. He hastened and
began with women here because the temptation of them is greater for
men
[music],
as the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "He did not leave behind anything that would
tempt men with women."
This is
also a recommendation for men.  For a woman to be righteous and to avoid
being a gateway to temptation, the
hoarded treasures of gold and silver—scholars have differed
in their interpretation,
but the gist of the interpretation is that it refers to abundant wealth.
God Almighty has entrusted us with hoarded treasures, and
these things are
beloved by the servant.
However, if this
love leads to righteous deeds, then this is a praiseworthy love,
as mentioned in the narration of Umar: "O God, we cannot help
but rejoice." Then he said, "I will spend it in its due right, so that
love is accompanied by fulfilling the obligatory right." [The following appears to be a separate, unrelated fragment:] "A
person's affair—
God is with him—
we can be happy with those things you
have made in our eyes, so when he uses those things which is pleasing to him, they are good
for him." [The following appears to be a separate, unrelated fragment:] And the marked horses—the marked ones, meaning the grazing
horses
or those with a white blaze and a white marking
on their foreheads or legs. [
Music]
Then he mentioned the hadith of Hakim bin Hizam, who said, "
I asked the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and he
gave me. Then I asked him again, and he gave me. Then I asked him again, and he
gave me."
[Music] And from Hakim bin Hizam, may God bless him and grant him peace, he said, "This wealth, O Hakim, this wealth is green and sweet. Whoever takes it willingly will be blessed in it." [Music]
And from  He took it with a self-importance that was not blessed for him, and he was
like one who eats but does not resemble. The
upper hand is better than the lower hand.
In this hadith, there is an
explanation of the obligation to be independent
of people and
to refrain from begging.
[Music] [Music]
And begging, as Sheikh al-Islam said, is not permissible except in cases of
necessity.
[Music]
Islam, may God have mercy on him.
This is unlike when someone is given
something on the condition that he does not ask
or be greedy. Being greedy means that he likes
people to give to him. He saw
people distributing things and came, even if he did not ask. This is greedyness.
[Music] The
upper hand
was explained in the hadith of Ibn Umar as the
giving hand. The upper hand is the one that
takes, and the upper hand is the one that gives. The lower hand is the one that
gives, and this one is the lower hand
because it diminishes itself and consults people and asks them.
This is not permissible, as we said, except in cases of necessity. [
Music]
It is known that the one who asks people for something
increases his sin if it is without need, and he will come on the Day of
Resurrection with no [blessing] on his face.  He tore the meat because he exposed
his face to people
[music].
This hadith also demonstrates the generosity of the Messenger of Allah, may God bless him and grant him peace, and that one of the
reasons for obtaining blessings is that
if he takes it willingly, then one of the reasons for its removal is
this questioning, anticipation, and
belittling of the self until he takes these funds.
[music]
From
the chapter "His wealth is his,"
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Harith ibn Suwaid. Abdullah
said: The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: "Which of you
loves the wealth of his heir more than his own wealth?"
[music]
Abdullah, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said: "O Messenger of God, there is no one among us who does not love his own wealth more." He
said: "His wealth is what he has sent forth, and the wealth of his heir is what he has left behind."
[music] The
Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, indicates here in this
hadith
that true wealth is the wealth from which the
servant benefits, and what the servant benefits from is what
benefits him in the Hereafter.
God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
clarified that there is wealth for his heir and wealth for him.
He asked the Companions: "
Who loves the wealth of his heir more than his own wealth?" They said: "We all
love our wealth." He said: "No, your wealth and what you spend in the way of
God."  As for the money you possess, in reality,
you will die and leave it to your children, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
God Almighty and the Exalted. So, what one gives in charity
during their life, in acts of righteousness, is what
remains for them in the Hereafter and benefits them.
[Music]
This contains the encouragement and exhortation to
give what can be given of money
in acts of goodness, righteousness, charity, and benevolence.
[Music]
And some of them expect their heirs to build a mosque for them
or to donate a well or something else. How do you know that
they will not do good for you in
your life?
They slaughtered a sheep, and the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said, "
What remains of it?"
[Music] She
said, "Nothing remains of it except its writings." So the
Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said, "All of it remains
except its shoulder, because true permanence and lasting reward is
what benefits you in your life." May God bless him and grant him peace. He
said, "Chapter: The wealthy are the ones who are poor." And the Almighty's saying: "
Whoever desires the life of this world and its adornments -
We fully repay them for their deeds therein, and they therein will not be
deprived. Those are the ones for whom there is nothing in the Hereafter but the
Fire. What they did therein is lost, and what they used to
do is worthless." The Imam, may God have mercy on him, and
desires
to them
The wages of
and will
[music]
and the meaning of the wealthy are the poor. The
wealthy accumulate wealth but do not spend it
in the way of God, nor do they give charity with it. These are the ones who will have the least reward on
the Day of Resurrection.
God, the Exalted, urged and
mentioned the verse in which it says that a servant's will should
be for
God, the Almighty, and not for the world, and he should not work
for the sake of the world.
God
[music] the Exalted,
then mentioned the hadith of Abu Dharr, who said: I went out one night and saw the
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
walking alone, with no one with him, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace.
I thought that he disliked having anyone walk with him, so I
walked in the shade of the moon. He turned around and saw me
[music]
God, may God bless him and grant him
peace, and said: Who is this? I said: Abu Dharr, may God make me your ransom. He said: So I walked with him for an hour, O Abu Dharr, come here. I walked with him for an hour. The wealthy are the poor on the Day of Resurrection, except for those whom God has given good, so he spends it to his right and his left, before him and behind him,
and does good with it, may God bless him and grant him peace. And
this is as we mentioned,
that the wealthy in this world  They are the ones with little reward on
the Day of Resurrection. Whoever has a heart that is full of good deeds is a loser
compared to those whose reward is abundant.
Look at how this charitable person is,
meaning that he gives charity to his right and his left. There is no
door of goodness that is opened for him except that he enters it, may God Almighty be glorified and exalted. Do
not belittle any good deed, for
even a small act of charity may be the reason for your salvation. Do not belittle any small act of charity.
Abu said, "I walked with him for an hour, and he said to me, 'Sit down.' So he
sat me down in a valley surrounded by stones and said, 'Sit
here until I return to you.' So he went into the lava field and stayed away from me for a long time.
Then I heard him coming and
saying, '
[Music] and
jumping
[Music].' So
Abu Dharr asked him, 'Who is this? Why did he speak, O Messenger of
God?' Abu Dharr
[Music]
explained that it was Gabriel who appeared to him and said to him, 'Give
your nation the good news that whoever dies without associating anything with God will
enter Paradise, Glory be to Him.' I
said, 'O Gabriel, even if he committed adultery?' He said, 'Yes.' I said, 'Even if he
stole and committed adultery?' He said, 'Yes, even if he drank
[Music].' And
this  It contains an explanation of the virtue of "There is no god but Allah," the
virtue of monotheism, and
it contains an explanation of the creed of Ahlus Sunnah wal Jama'ah that whoever
commits a major sin does not become an unbeliever and
his fate is Paradise. He is under the will of Allah; He wills his punishment and He will
forgive him. And whoever enters Hell, his fate is
Paradise.
This does not mean leniency towards such major sins, for
entering Hell, even for a moment, is a great destruction.
[Music] It has been
narrated from the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, that a
man who was one of the richest
people in the world will be dipped
into Hell once, and it will be said to him, "Have you ever experienced
hardship? Have you ever experienced any blessing? Have you ever experienced any
joy?" He will say, "No, my Lord." He will forget all
joy and blessings in one dip. So what about those who are in the
lowest level of Hell? May Allah protect us and you.
Sheikh H. Allah
will resurrection. He will be dipped into the
fire and it will be said to him, "Have you ever experienced any blessing, bliss, or happiness in the worldly
life?" And he will say, "No." Meaning,
he will forget every single blessing and
moment of joy and happiness
that occurred to him in this life. He said, "
How about...?"  The one who was in the lowest
[music] If the one who suffers the least punishment in Hell is a man under whose feet Abu Tale’ has a burning ember placed, from which his brain boils.
He said, “Chapter on the saying of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, ‘I would not like to have
gold equal to Mount Uhud.’”
The Imam, may God have mercy on him,
then mentioned the hadith of Abu Dharr, similar to the previous hadith, the hadith of
Abu, may God be pleased with him,
in this wording, as he mentioned in the chapter.
He said, “I would not be pleased to have gold equal to Mount Uhud, and three
days would pass and I would still have a
dinar of it, except for something I would set aside to repay a debt.” May God bless him and grant him peace.
God Almighty and
his saying here, “except for something I would set aside to repay a debt,” contains the
obligation to return rights to their owners. Do not take a
loan from people and then neglect them.
You must return it, and returning rights to
their owners and the debt to its owner takes precedence over giving charity.
The development, may
God bless him and grant him peace
[music]
He said, “Except that I would spend it among the servants of God in this way, and in this way, and in this way,” meaning,
spend it in the ways of good. This contains the
encouragement to spend in the various ways of good. And
in this hadith also is the manners of Abu Dharr, may God be pleased with
him, and his eagerness to follow the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace.
And this is the state  The noble Companions, may
God bless him and grant him peace, said, and
then he also said in another narration, “If I had gold
equal to Mount Uhud, I would be pleased if three nights did not pass and I still had some of it,
except for something I would set aside with you.” The
hadith of the Prophet, may God bless him
and grant him peace, regarding Mount Uhud, and in his saying, “If I had gold equal to Mount Uhud,” there is permissibility in using the word “if” if it is used in the sense of wishing for good, but it is prohibited if it is used in the sense of wishing for evil or
if it is an objection to God’s decree and predestination. The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said, “If I had gold equal to Mount Uhud,” and in his saying, “If I had gold equal to Mount Uhud,” there is permissibility in using the word “if” if it is used in the sense of wishing for evil or if it is used to object to God’s decree and predestination. This
also contains
encouragement to spend money during life and
health,
and giving preference to spending during illness and when death is near.
[Music]
This is preferred for two reasons:
First, because there is no guarantee against
injustice in a will.
Some people bequeath
a third of their estate in charity. This is better. Giving
charity during life is better because you might make a will and
not have it carried out.
[Music] The
second reason is the lack of guarantee against delay.
Your money might be lost, a calamity might befall you.
Hasten to do good deeds.
[Music] He
said, “The chapter on wealth is the wealth of the soul,” and the words of God Almighty, “Do
they think that what We extend to them of wealth…”  And Banin,
to his saying, “Besides that, they are working for it.”
Ibn ‘Uyaynah said, “They did
not work for it, but they must work for it.” The
Imam, may God
have mercy on him, and Ibn ‘Uyaynah, first in the chapter, explaining the meaning of true wealth, and that the truly wealthy person is the one who is rich in spirit, not the one who is rich in money. The wealth of the soul means being content with what God has given him, being satisfied with what God has provided, and being pleased with it. This is the wealth of the soul.
What generates the wealth of the soul is the wealth of the heart from
its attachment to God, the Exalted. This is the
meaning of God’s saying, “And He found you in need and made you rich.” The wealth of the
soul. The verse was Meccan,
and the state of the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, in that
regard is not hidden. God, the Exalted, may God bless him and grant him peace. This is what is indicated by the aforementioned hadith, the hadith of Abu Hurayrah: “Wealth is not about having many possessions, but true wealth is the wealth of the soul.” “Possessions” means the goods of this world. The hadith of Abu Hurayrah, may God be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him. The verse
means that whoever
God has given wealth and provided for in
this worldly life should not think that it is due to
his honor, for it may
be
God Almighty will gradually lead him astray, then punish him. And do not
think that abundance is to own nobility is grading him. [Music] And those who disbelieve think that We
only grant them respite for their own good. We only grant them respite so that they may increase in sin. We grant respite, meaning We
give the
blessings of
God Almighty.
[Music]
sin and ob.
Yes, he
said, Chapter on the Virtue of Poverty.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned in it the hadith of Sahl ibn Sa'd, who said: A man passed
by the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, and he said to
a man sitting with him, "
What is your opinion of the
hadith of Sahl ibn Sa'd, may God be pleased with him?"
God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said, "A man from the nobles of the people said, 'By God, this man is worthy, if he proposes marriage, to be given in marriage, and if he intercedes, to have his intercession accepted.'"
[Music] Then another man passed by, and the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said to him, "What is your opinion of this man?" [Music] He
said, "O Messenger of God, this man is from the poor of the
Muslims. This man is worthy, if he proposes marriage, to be given in marriage, and if he intercedes, to have his intercession accepted, and if he speaks, to have his words
heard."
[Music]
This man is
from the people of the earth, like this one, may
God bless him and grant him peace. And
this is evidence
that goodness is with God.  Glory be to Him, it is through
piety and not through wealth. And
here the disagreement between scholars has been lengthy, and their words are about
which is better, poverty or wealth, and each has evidence.
[Music] Talk
about this issue in brief.
First, what
is meant by wealth and poverty here, which is better?   It is
money,
not the wealth of the soul or the poverty of God
Almighty.
[Music] [
Music]
[Music] It is
also necessary to know
that wealth and poverty related to money are trials by which
the servant is tested, and We will test you with evil and good as a
trial. So the discussion is not about looking at the money itself, but rather about what is related to it in terms of work and performing good deeds or other things. May God grant me a long life. [Music] Also, among the important things is that the place of preference is when they are equal in good deeds. The result of that is
what Sheikh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah said:
If they are equal in piety, then they are equal in merit. If they are equal
in piety, then they are
equal in merit. Sheikh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah, may
God Almighty have mercy on him, and
God Almighty, and the next. And it does
not mean preferring poverty for those who say it
and guiding them not to earn a living and
not to seek worldly things or work and that they should be content with what is
in the hands of people.
This is not what is commanded. Rather, the servant is commanded to strive. And do
not forget the calamity of this world.
[Music]
God Almighty.
Imam Ahmad, may God have mercy on him, said: All people should
rely on God and accustom themselves  The
Imam Ahmad, may
God Almighty have mercy on him, said: The
essence of this hadith is
that the important thing is not outward appearances,
but inner character and piety.
This is as in the hadith: “A disheveled, dusty man, turned away from doors, who has
no power. If he were to swear by God, he would inherit.” May God’s peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
God Almighty.
Then he mentioned a hadith from
Abu Wael: “We visited Khabbab when he
was sick, and
he said: ‘We emigrated with the Prophet, may God’s peace and blessings be upon him,
seeking God’s favor, so
our reward is with God.’” My
Imam, may God
Almighty have mercy on him, said: “At the end of the month of Ramadan, we did
not receive our due reward.
Among them was Mus’ab ibn ‘Umair, who was killed on the day of Uhud. He left behind his cloak.
If we covered his head, his feet were exposed. If we covered his feet, his head was exposed. The
Prophet, may God’s peace and blessings be upon him, ordered us to
cover his head and place some sweet-smelling grass on his feet. And among us are those whose reward has ripened, and they are reaping it. Mus’ab ibn ‘
Umair [
Music] [Music] [
Music]
This highlights the virtue of Mus’ab ibn ‘Umair, who died a martyr on
the day of Uhud and
was the standard-bearer.  In the battle,
the hadith of
Mus'ab ibn 'Umair, may God be pleased with him,
is explained here,
of course, by his saying, "Here he left a garment." The garment is a loincloth made
of wool,
and his saying, "He plucks it," means he picks it. This is these
fruits. Here, on the other hand, some of
us are plucking them. Here are
the divisions of the Companions, may God be pleased with them, according to what
Abu Dharr mentioned,
or according to what Khabbab mentioned. The
first division is those who
died before the conquests, the acquisition of wealth, and the spread of
Islam.
[Music]
As for those who lived afterward, they are
also divided into divisions. Some of them
turned away from wealth,
took it, and shared it with the poor. These remained in the
first state, like Abu Dharr, and they are connected to
the first division.
[Music] The second division is those who lived comfortably and expanded in permissible things, but did not accumulate much. These are many, like Ibn 'Umar, may God be pleased with him. [Music] May
God be pleased with them both. And some of them increased and accumulated wealth through
trade and other things, while fulfilling obligatory and
recommended duties. These are
also many, like 'Abd al-Rahman ibn 'Awf, may God be pleased with
him.
This is what Khabbab indicated in the chapter, may
God be pleased with him.  It was narrated from him that he
said: Some of them received their reward and
passed away without taking anything for it, and some of them had their worldly possessions readily available, so they pursued and
seized them.
[Music] The
first category, and whoever joins them, will have their reward fully provided for them in the
Hereafter.
The second category, which is based on the
implication of the narration
and the hadith, is that what they received of
worldly wealth will be counted against their
reward in the Hereafter because their reward is diminished according to
what came to them.
[Music]
This is as in the hadith: "No warrior goes on a raid and gains
spoils
[Music] and
returns, except that they postpone a third of their reward," meaning they postpone it,
which is the spoils. This is the hadith of
God, may God bless him and grant him peace.
Therefore,
many of the early Muslims preferred little wealth and were content with it so that their
reward would be fully provided for them in the Hereafter and
their reckoning for this wealth would be lessened.
[Music]
From this, it should be noted that if
you do good in this world,
do not seek a worldly reward. Rather,
even if you do good for your brother and he prays for you,
pray for him so that your reward is not limited to this prayer. Or if
you hope that he will guide you, or you hope that he will give to you, or you hope that he will thank
you, pray for him so that your
reward is fully provided for you.  He who hastens to do something in this
world.
And this is why it is important to
mention here, and that is when you do something
good, do not seek by way of the world. Mention if it is for you, make it back for him, do not ask
anything from him, do not take
anything from him, so your reward is complete.
Mention the hadith of Imran bin Hussein
on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who said: “I looked
into Paradise and saw that most of its inhabitants were the poor. And I looked
into Hell and saw that most of its inhabitants were women.”
This also contains not just information,
but also encouragement to refrain from excessive pursuit of
worldly things, and that if you obtain
something in this world, fulfill its rights
and obligations.
[Music]
It also contains an encouragement for women to fear God, to increase
good deeds, and to
preserve the religion. This is a serious matter.
[Music]
God Almighty.
Likewise, this hadith is
among the evidence that Paradise and Hell exist and are
created, as is the belief of the Sunnis.
Mention the hadith of Anas who said: “The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, did not eat
at a table until he died, and he did not eat thin bread
until he died.”
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, the hadith of Anas, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
This shows the Prophet's asceticism, may God bless him and grant him peace, and
his turning away from the world, even though the world
opened up to him at the end of his life and he acquired spoils of war. But he did
not desire
the world; he slept on a mat and rarely
lit a fire in his house.
He said, "I did not eat thin bread until I
died."
Yes, may
God bless him and grant him peace.
And you find that even at the end of life, even though the world opened up to him, he did not want anything from it. Rather,
he used to sleep on a
mat and not a single fire was lit
inside his house for weeks on,
and he would not even eat a
thin sheet of bread. He mentioned the hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her, and the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, died, and there was nothing in my shelf that a living being could eat except half a barley grain in my shelf. I ate from it until it was gone, so I measured it and it was finished.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, narrated the hadith of
Aisha, may God be pleased with her.
[Music] May God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
In this hadith is a demonstration of the
Prophet's asceticism, may God bless him and grant him peace, as mentioned in the
hadith of
God, may God bless him and grant him peace. It
also shows that
when a servant receives sustenance,
he should not strive to
count or enumerate it, wondering
when it will be exhausted or when it will disappear.  This is one of the things that
removes blessings,
as in his saying, "I measured it," meaning
I looked at what I had and then weighed it, how much of it remained. This was one
of the reasons for the removal of blessings.
[Music]
This is like his saying, peace and blessings be upon him, in the hadith of
Asma, "Do
not be presumptuous, for God will be presumptuous towards you." Meaning, do not estimate
things, for God is presumptuous towards you, meaning He will calculate
what exists for you and deal with you according to your own estimation. Rather, entrust the matter to God, and let
your reliance be upon God, the Exalted. This is the meaning of the
hadith.
We will make you a symbol, peace and blessings be upon him, the
hadith of Asma,
meaning
[Music]
God, the Exalted, and then God, the Exalted, and
then the
chapter on how the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and his
companions lived, their detachment from the world. The
Imam, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned in it the hadith of Abu Hurairah,
and the hadith of Abu Hurairah, who said, "By
God, besides Whom there is no other god, I would not lean
my liver on the ground from hunger." [
Hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him] God, the
Exalted,
and I would tie a stone to my stomach from hunger.
This also indicates asceticism.  The Companions were detached from
worldly affairs, especially Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, and his virtue. He devoted himself to the
hadith of the Messenger, peace and blessings be upon him, and the pursuit of knowledge.
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, said, "One
day I sat on the path they used to take when
Abu Bakr passed by.
I asked him about a verse from the Book of God, only asking to satisfy my need. He passed by without answering.
[Music] May God be pleased with him. Your
father, may God be pleased with him.
God Almighty.
[Music] This also demonstrates Abu Hurairah's chastity, may God be pleased with him, and his self-sufficiency in not asking, despite his need. [Music]
Umar passed by and experienced the same thing as Abu Bakr.
Then Abu al-Qasim, may God be pleased with him, passed by. He smiled
when he saw me and knew what was in my heart and what was on my face.
Abu al-Qasim, may God be pleased with him,
[Music]
then said, 'O Abu Hurairah!' I replied, 'At your service, O Messenger of God!' He
said, 'Come with me,' and I followed him. He entered, asked permission to enter, and was granted it.
Abu Hurairah responded, 'At your service, O
God!'
[Music]
He found milk in a cup and asked, 'Where did this come from?'"  The milk,
they said, was given to you by so-and-so
[music].
Abu Hurayrah said, "O Messenger of God, go
to the people of the Suffah and invite them to
[music]."
The people of the Suffah were
among them. He said, "The guests of Islam do not take refuge with anyone,
nor with anyone's wealth. If charity comes to him, he sends it to them and does
not take anything from it. If
a gift comes to him, he sends it to them and takes some of it and shares it with them."
Abu Hurayrah said, "That saddened me because the milk was scarce.
I invited these people, who were numerous in the mosque." The
people of the Suffah were sitting in the mosque. He said, "
What is this milk for the people of the Suffah? I am more deserving to take a
drink of this milk to strengthen myself."
[music] He
said, "When he came, he commanded me, and I would give it to them. What could I possibly
get from this milk? There is no alternative to obeying God and His Messenger, may
God bless him and grant him peace." [
music] He
said, "So I went to them and invited them, and they came. They asked permission, and he granted it to
them, and they took their places in
[music]
in  Some accounts state that there were 70 of the Companions of
the Row.
He said, "O Abu Hurayrah, at your service, O Messenger of Allah." He said, "Take it and
give it to them."
[Music] He
said, "So I took this small vessel containing the
milk and began giving it to each man to drink from
until he was satisfied. Then I
gave it to another man to drink until he was satisfied, and they continued
until I reached the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and
all the people had drunk their fill."
[Music]
He took the vessel and placed it in his hand, smiled, and said, "
Only you and I remain, O
Messenger of
Allah." He said, "
Sit down and drink." So I drank. He said, "Drink." So I drank. He kept
saying, "Drink,"
until I said, "No, by the One Who sent you with the truth, I cannot drink any more."
[Music] And
this is in it  Among the benefits of this hadith is the importance of
concealing one's needs,
as hinting at them is better than stating them outright,
as Abu Hurairah did with Bakr and Umar.
[Music]
Another benefit of this hadith is the generosity of the Messenger of Allah (peace and blessings be upon him) and
his preference for others
over himself and his family, as well as the poor Companions of the Suffah.
[Music] The
hadith also
highlights the hardship faced by the Companions,
especially the poor among them, the Companions of the Suffah.
Furthermore, the hadith demonstrates the virtue of Abu Hurairah (may Allah be pleased with
him) and
his abstinence from asking for help, prioritizing
obedience to the Messenger of Allah (peace and blessings be upon him) over his own desires, such as
drinking milk.
[Music]
This hadith also contains a sign of the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him)
and one of the signs of
his prophethood:
the abundance of drink and food
in his hand.
[Music]
Another benefit of this hadith is the hadith about drinking while sitting. He said, "Sit down and drink." [Music] Also, the hadith
indicates that the last person to drink was the one who served them. The one who drank
here is the Prophet (peace and
blessings be upon him).
The benefits of
praising God Almighty for His blessings and saying "Bismillah" before
drinking.
[Music]
Yes, and here we pause until the next lesson, God willing. And
God knows best. May God's peace, blessings, and mercy be upon our Prophet. May
God's peace, blessings, and mercy be upon our Prophet Muhammad and upon his family.